♪ ♪
>> Tucker: APPARENTLY IT'S NOT
ENOUGH OF THE TECH COMPANIES TO
KNOW WHAT YOU DO, AND THEY DO
KNOW WHAT YOU DO.
INCREASINGLY THEY WANT TO
CONTROL WHAT YOU DO AND WHAT YOU
SEE AND WHAT YOU THINK.
DURING A RECENT MEETING WITH
INVESTORS, FACEBOOK CEO
MARK ZUCKERBERG REVEALED THAT
HIS COMPANY HAS BEEN RANKING
NEWS OUTLETS BY HOW TRUSTWORTHY
THEY ARE WITH LESS TRUSTED
OUTLETS BEING PENALIZED ON
FACEBOOK'S NEW SPEED.
TRUSTED BY THE WAY BY FACEBOOK,
NOT BY YOU, BUT I
MARK ZUCKERBERG AND HIS
DEPUTIES.
MEANWHILE, TWITTER IS
INSTITUTING A SYSTEM TO SUPPRESS
TWEETS HE REGARDS AS HARASSMENT
EVEN IF THEY ACTUALLY BREAK NO
RULES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE POLITICAL
ORIENTATION OF THE TWEETS.
BRETT LARSON HOSTS FOX NEWS NEWS
HEADLINES 24/7 AND INVESTIGATED
BIG TECH FOR THE SHOW.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATING THE
STORY OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS
NOW.
INVOLVING FACEBOOK CHANGES TO
HOW THEY HANDLE NEWS SOURCES IN
USER'S NEWSFEED.
AS YOU MENTION IN A MEETING WITH
MEDIA COMPANY EXECUTIVES FROM
"NEW YORK TIMES" TO NEWS CORP.,
THE PARENT COMPANY OF FOX NEWS,
FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
SAID THEY WILL BE RELYING ON
USER SURVEYS TO DETERMINE WHICH
NEWS SOURCES ARE "BROADLY
TRUSTED."
THE COMMENTS WERE MADE FOLLOWING
FACEBOOK'S F8 DEVELOPER
CONFERENCE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MONTH AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
MANY CHANGES THE SOCIAL MEDIA
GIANT HAS MADE IN AN EFFORT TO
COMBAT FAKE NEWS, FAKE ACCOUNTS
AND BOTS THAT HELP AMPLIFY AND
SPREAD FAKE INFORMATION.
I SPOKE WITH FACEBOOK EARLIER
TODAY AND THEY ASSURED ME THAT
THIS ISN'T AN EFFORT TO CENSOR
ANY IDEAS OR BELIEFS AND AT THE
RANDOM SAMPLING OF
TRUSTWORTHINESS HAPPENS
FREQUENTLY TO ENSURE SITES ARE
GETTING A FAIR SHAKE.
THE USER WILL BE PRESENTED WITH
A SIMPLE YES OR NO QUESTION, ARE
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE SITE?
A "YES" ANSWER BRINGS UP THE
NEXT QUESTION.
TOO RATED FOR TRUSTWORTHINESS ON
A SCALE OF 1-5.
WHAT ABOUT FAKE ACCOUNTS
BOOSTING THE TRUSTWORTHINESS OF
A NOT SO TRUSTWORTHY NEWS
OUTLET?
FACEBOOK JUST THIS YEAR HAS
REMOVED MORE THAN HALF A BILLION
FAKE ACCOUNTS.
FURTHER, THOSE HEADLINES LIKE
THEY PULLED OVER TO HELP THIS
DOG, WHAT HAPPENS NEXT WILL
AMAZE YOU,...
, NOT GOING TO GET THE KIND OF
RANKING IN YOUR NEWSFEED GOING
FORWARD.
THE CHANGES ARE ALSO A CRACKDOWN
SO-CALLED CLICKBAIT AND NEWS,
ESPECIALLY LOCAL NEWS.
AS FOR PAYING PROVIDERS FOR THE
NEWS, NO DEAL.
CABLE OPERATORS PAY TO CARRY
CHANNELS LIKE FOX FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS BUT WHEN ASKED IF
FACEBOOK WILL DO BUT ASSUME
THING DON'T LIKE TO MAKE SAME
THING, THEY ARE GIANT SAYING
THEY DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR THAT
DESPITE THE FACT THEY ARE
RELYING ON LOCAL NEWS, IT WOULD
SEEM THAT KIND OF NEW REVENUE
WOULD BREATHE LIFE INTO LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS AT OUTLETS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO REMAIN RELEVANT
AND PROFITABLE.
THESE CHANGES ON HELPING US FEEL
ANY BETTER.
AN EFFORT TO SEE MORE NEWS FROM
FRIENDS AND WAS NEWS FOR MEDIA
SITES ACTUALLY PUTS US IN A BAD
MOOD BECAUSE WE COMPARE
OURSELVES TO OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
APPEARANCE AND WE SEE WHAT WE
ARE MISSING OUT ON.
PARTIES AND AWESOME VACATIONS
THAT WE ARE NOT ON.
TUCKER.
IT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE INFORMED, WE
WANT TO FEEL BAD!
[LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: WE NEED A VACATION
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.